Are you manipulating all parts of your research
Why are you doing this to yourself
Here's some websites
You don't want to know
Because it will make your life easier
When you use those
To
Not later than twenty twenty one to make you water more
Find articles related to your study
Theories
That applies to your studies
And how you can do your metroology
Of course
Use this with cushion
Because sometimes leading is his genergenerating results
So you always need to double check
But what if I tell you that chachi pt is helpful
But there is a new enemy
He is the bored one
That I created content about Bart
There are many in my comment section that no gate keep bart
The bart is the difference between him and the chat gpt
It is connected to the internet
These are the recent study season literatures
You will have access to them
Its only downside
He won't remember your other prompts
Unlike chat gpt
Because the first proms he will remember
So it seems like you just have a converse on
So we still have option three microsoft bing
Ask about articles if you are struggling
How to organize your ideas for yours
rrl or use bing
In the age of ai
So make sure to leverage them and to optimize them
Good luck and don't forget to follow for more